创作内容给了我很多机会，但我每天能投入在创作上的时间有限。所以，我一直在思考如何重新设计我的内容创作流程，让它基于AI或者有AI辅助。
另一个我想解决的问题是，如何让员工在从事全职工作的同时，尽可能轻松地成为创作者。这就是我这个内容机器的灵感来源，主要就是针对这两个问题。
这个内容机器的想法就是为了优化这两个问题。
>> 我确实读过你的帖子，它们很不错。所以，它们并不像那些垃圾内容，但请你现场证明给我们看。我们该怎么做呢？
>> 那么，内容机器的第一步叫做“神谕”。它只扫描我所在的所有频道过去7天的信息，然后排列出一份简短的想法清单。它有一个完整的评分系统，用来定义什么是好的内容爆点，并给出正面评分。我基本上能获得15个内容爆点。
评分系统会定义什么是好的内容爆点，并给予正面评分。我基本上能收到15个内容爆点。
>> AI刚出来的时候，写作能力确实很差。你怎样才能让它不写出那些垃圾内容呢？
>> 在我看来，内容机器唯一会产生垃圾内容的时候，更多是因为在访谈环节没有分享出足够好的想法，而不是AI写得不好。
>> 哎呀，所以你的意思是说，我们才是那些垃圾内容？
>> 我的看法是，AI垃圾内容好笑的地方在于，人们其实是在指着自己说我不够聪明。
[音乐]
>> 欢迎收听《How I AI》。我是克莱尔·韦尔，产品负责人兼AI狂热爱好者，我的使命是帮助你更好地使用这些新工具。今天，我们有幸邀请到了10x公司的亚历克斯·利伯曼，他将向我们展示如何攀登“尴尬之山”，也就是如何利用AI在公司里建立内容机器。你猜怎么着？他没有产出垃圾内容。这个工作流程对于任何想推广自己公司、在分发上获得优势的人来说都非常棒。让我们开始吧。今天的节目由Fire Crawl赞助。
在他的公司里利用AI建立一个内容机器。你猜怎么着？他没有产出垃圾内容。这个工作流程对于任何想推广自己公司和在分发上获得优势的人来说都非常棒。我们开始吧。现在请听今天赞助商Fire Crawl的广告。
我们现在请出今天的赞助商Fire Crawl。如果你正在用AI代理构建应用，你可能也遇到了同样的难题。你的代理需要网页数据，但恰当的页面难以找到，被JavaScript隐藏，或需要登录才能访问。
Firecrawl是一个网络数据API，它能让代理大规模地搜索、抓取和与网页交互，并获得它们能实际使用的、干净的结构化数据。超过一百万开发者，包括我自己，都在使用它。它是开源的，而且可以免费开始使用。
它是开源的，而且免费开始使用。[音乐]别再去和网页数据较劲了，改用Firecrawl来驱动你的AI代理和应用吧，访问firecrawl.dev。使用代码howiai，你今天就能获得10,000个免费积分。
>> 亚历克斯，我对这期节目很兴奋，因为我告诉每个人，要想成功，特别是作为白手起家的创业者，你必须做一件事，不是“氛围检查”，而是攀登“尴尬之山”。你必须发帖。
你必须在X上发帖，必须在LinkedIn上发帖，必须谈论自己。我会说，作为一个纯正的工程师，我愿意做任何事来避免谈论我的生意。
[笑声]
>> 大家对此不会感到意外。所以，请告诉我，你是如何开始使用AI的？你为什么开始使用AI来构建公司的内容引擎？
>> 首先，非常感谢你的邀请。我完全认同攀登AI尴尬之山的说法。我可能站在完全相反的位置，也就是，我愿意尴尬，愿意尝试很多次来推销我所做的事情，因为我相信，那些认为“如果你建好了，他们就会来”的人，在这个分发比以往任何时候都重要的世界里，我不认为情况一定是那样，或者大部分时候都不是。
尽可能多地射门来推销我正在做的事情，因为我相信，那些认为“如果你建好了，他们就会来”的人，在这个分发比以往任何时候都重要的世界里，我不认为情况一定是那样，或者大部分时候都不是。
我认为情况不一定如此，或者大部分时候并非如此。所以，基本上在10x公司的背景下，我一直试图解决两个问题。对于那些不了解10x的人，它是一家应用AI公司，帮助中端市场和企业客户完成AI转型。我们提供从战略到部署工程的全方位服务。首先，我过去10年一直在互联网上创作内容，基本上从我大学创办Morning Brew时就开始了。
帮助中端市场和企业客户完成AI转型。我们提供从战略到部署工程的全方位服务。所以，第一个问题是，我过去10年一直在互联网上创作内容，基本上从我大学创办Morning Brew时就开始了。
基本上从我在大学创办Morning Brew时开始，我就一直在创作内容。我认为创作内容给了我很多机会，但我每天能投入在创作上的时间有限。比如我会说...
假设我25%的时间可以用来做内容。所以我一直在想，怎么最大化利用这25%的时间？我思考了很多的是，如何重新设计我的内容流程，让它
成为原生AI或AI辅助的，同时确保我不会输出那种AI垃圾内容，因为我觉得正是那种内容让很多人对AI产生反感，尤其是在内容创作方面，感觉AI只会吐出一些
非常平庸的东西，听起来和网上说过的其他内容没什么两样。第二是，你知道，我建立的每个企业，无论是媒体公司还是非媒体公司，我认为未来我们需要更多地考虑在业务之上建立媒体公司。
原因是在后AI时代，技术比以往任何时候都更加商品化，商业护城河越来越少，我相信可信的传播渠道就是其中之一。所以，总的来说，我正在构建一个媒体
公司，建立在10X之上，而且我认为，你知道，我会做所有显而易见的事情，比如聘请全职创作者加入员工队伍，聘请写手，我们会有一份通讯，所有这些事情。但我认为没有多少公司会考虑把自己的
员工变成创作者，如果他们想这样做的话。所以我一直在尝试解决的另一个问题是，如何尽最大可能让员工在拥有全职工作的同时轻松成为创作者？这就是
这个内容机器想法的起源，就是为了优化这两个问题。
>> 我喜欢这一点，因为第一，我自己也经历过。你知道，我是TikTok的首席产品官。我经历过这个阶段，我当时想，你知道吗？当我担任这些职位时，作为高管的一部分工作就是
成为公司的营销代言人，你知道，我以前常说在SaaS领域，你不是在买产品，而是在买路线图，我会告诉我的团队，他们买的不是路线图，而是团队，这
就是说他们相信这个团队能够执行愿景，所以他们想通过订阅或参与度或其他方式来押注这个团队。我现在和很多CEO交谈，他们对当前的
营销状况感到不安，现有的渠道回报递减，他们看不到老一套方法真正奏效，我告诉他们每一个人，你们的第一营销渠道应该是你们的员工。所以我喜欢
你在这方面投资。现在我最担心的是，嗯，我也有点，你知道，内容分发引擎，其中包含一些AI。AI开箱即用，在写吸引人的文案方面相当糟糕。而且
我想我们都见过这种情况。我们都对它非常挑剔，但看起来你已经解决了这个问题。所以我很想听听你的流程，你认为AI适合在哪里，不适合在哪里，你如何让它不写出垃圾内容。
>> 是的，完全同意。我在这里有几点想法。我们之前谈过这个，即Lulu Meservey谈到过这个观点，世界上最优秀的作家使用AI是一种遗憾，因为他们限制了自己的上限，所以她的观点是AI会
提高差作家的下限，但会限制优秀作家的上限。我想我同意这个观点，但有一些细微差别。我要说的第一点是，写作和创作内容是一个多步骤的过程，我们会
一步步来看。我认为仅仅说在内容过程的任何部分使用AI都会降低你的上限并不一定正确。我想如果我们说在内容过程的实际起草或编辑部分，
使用AI会降低你的上限，我可以接受，而且我能理解如果你是一位有天赋的作家，属于前1%的作家，基本上依赖一个在互联网整个语料库上训练过的模型，因此按定义会是平均水平的，而
你是一位高于平均水平或杰出的作家，为什么会更差，完全理解。但内容过程有很多部分，我认为其中一些部分你可以使用AI，同时实际上继续提高你的上限，而不是降低它。另一个
点是，我总是考虑替代方案。所以，对于我们10X团队来说，替代方案是，我们稍后可以谈谈我们如何激励人们创作，但在内容机器之前，替代方案就是
人们根本不创作内容。所以这就像，如果我两个选择，让人们围绕他们的专长和他们在工作中所做的事情来创作内容，还是不创作，我当然会每一天都选择第一个。
所以，我能做的是带你了解我如何思考我的内容过程，然后我如何转变它。尽管我们在使用AI做内容的背景下谈论这个，
但我们在10X的观点和我的观点是，你几乎可以用这种流程映射然后重建的方法来处理工作中的任何流程。这只是我所知道的世界。好的。所以，当我开始这个过程时，我基本上就是画出了
内容过程今天是如何运作的。所以，对于任何创作内容的人来说，你基本上从寻找灵感开始。从历史上看，最难的事情不仅仅是对于那些第一次尝试创作内容的人，
而是对任何人，我实际上会说尤其是创作者，是找到感觉新颖有趣的想法，而不是感觉像对已有内容的疲惫复读，这真的很难。所以第一步是找到
一个想法。第二步，或者说1B，如果这个想法与亲身经历相关，你觉得对这个想法完全了解，那么你可以跳过研究步骤。但对于很多想法，你需要研究。然后接下来
下一步，你要把所有想法都写在纸上，就像围绕这个主题把自己的思路全部倒出来。然后是确定核心格式，你想把内容做成什么样的形式，
无论是长篇网站文章、领英还是新闻简报等。然后你写下来，接着审阅草稿、修改，经过编辑流程，发布，然后就像加里·维所说的
内容金字塔理念，你把核心内容拆分成微内容，然后分发到所有社交媒体平台。所以这就是流程，无论是视频还是写作，内容创作就是这样进行的。
所以我一开始就是以此为基础，展示现状。在这个流程中，AI应该在哪里发挥作用？然后AI应该是主导者还是副驾驶？
我想暂停一下，因为咱们先不谈内容。这是我告诉所有人，在尝试弄清楚如何将AI应用到他们的日常工作、公司职能中的确切流程。
采用这种工作流优先的方法是把AI引入系统最切实的方式。所以，就像我写下来，然后做出那些决定，比如人类副驾驶自动化。我另外建议人们，
我说，不要根据你目前的约束条件来规划工作流程。你要在理想状态下，没有约束的情况下规划工作流。就像没有约束，你当然会把所有内容切割成多平台分发，
做成微内容。当然，在没有约束的情况下，你会有一个研究员时刻寻找和挖掘创意。所以我认为这两点，写出你的工作流程，以及去除现有约束来设计
工作流，非常重要。我们有一期节目，采访了Suzie的CEO Matt，他在他的营销团队中就是这样做的，他说他拿到一个通话记录，然后想‘我能从中提取多少东西？’不是
我的团队能提取多少，而是理论上。然后，他会从一份内容中衍生出一百个不同的东西。
完全正确。是的，百分之百。我们在与公司和客户做这种流程映射的过程中发现，首先，你最终会意识到，很多效率的提升甚至是在考虑使用AI之前就已经存在的，
因为大多数人之前并没有真正做过流程映射，而AI只是促使他们去做的推动力，然后他们在流程中发现了所有浪费。所以，我完全同意
这一点，这是不显眼的工作，但我真不知道，如果你不从这里开始，你怎么能重新构想你的工作。这也是为什么，当我们谈论AI导致失业等话题时，我唯一能
做到这一点的原因是因为我已经做过内容创作流程成千上万次了。所以这显示了拥有专业知识和垂直领域专长的重要性。至少目前，这些知识确实需要，
否则你无法重新构想工作。好的，所以我基本上把这个作为基础，下一步就是再次假设没有约束，重建整个系统。于是，就产生了这个叫做“内容机器”的东西。
我将给你展示一下它是如何工作的，先看视觉效果，然后带你看我实际运行这部机器。基本上，内容机器是这样运作的。第一步，
内容机器的第一步叫做“神谕”。整个理念是，内容机器只是一个技能目录，它是一个插件，你可以通过命令行界面或者Claude Coder Co-work来操作，
它连接了我10x的所有记录系统。比如我的Slack、Notion、会议记录、Linear、Git、Gmail。它连接到所有这些系统。基本上，神谕只是扫描过去7天来自
我所在所有渠道的信息，然后它会给出一份简短的创意列表，认为这些是好的内容火花。而且它有一个完整的评分系统来定义什么是好的内容火花。比如，如果有相关的故事或趣闻，它会给
积极的评分。如果有强烈的观点，它给积极评分。如果有具体的例子，它也给积极评分。所以，基本上我每天会得到15个内容灵感。其中一半来自神谕查看
我的内部系统。另一半则是进行所谓的“互联网阅读”，我给内容机器提供了一份我关注的X、LinkedIn账号列表以及我常访问的网站，
它会去查看这些人过去7天发布的所有内容，并把这些分享为灵感。比如，你就是我互联网阅读器关注的人之一，它会查看你过去7天发布的
所有内容，当它认为有一个好的内容灵感，比如我可以对你的一条帖子进行引用转发或回复，它就会把那个分享在列表中。所以，这是流程的第一步。光这一步，
可能就是这个系统中最有帮助的部分了。回到那个观点，即使你认为AI会制造废话内容，你不想让它起草你的内容，但只是帮你从
一张白纸到具体创意，我觉得这会大大降低摩擦，让你真正养成创作习惯。好的，然后你选一个创意，进入所谓的“面试小组”。基本上，面试小组是
我找了六位世界级的采访者，把他们的技巧都编码成了技能，包括蒂姆·费里斯、乔·罗根、迈克尔·巴巴罗、芭芭拉·沃尔特斯、霍华德·斯特恩，他们会轮流就这个话题向你提问，直到觉得信息够了，能创作出一篇内容了。
还有一点要补充，这里没显示，就是直接从Oracle跳到采访小组。如果你选的话题，你觉得自己还没完全掌握信息，可以运行研究助手，它会给你一份完整的话题简报。
咱们稍后会在Claude里看到具体的样子，但如果你选的话题，你觉得自己还没完全掌握信息，可以运行研究助手，它会给你一份完整的话题简报。
好了，我们通过采访小组。基本上，我做的事情就是，我用WhisperFlow把我的所有回答都语音转文字，然后它用我的声音来起草内容。
内容机器的工作方式就是，所有这些步骤都在内容机器的仓库里，我们团队每个人都在自己电脑上拉取了这个仓库。但与此同时，我们每个人都有个人文件夹，里面编码了我们的声音、风格指南，还有我们想获取灵感的内容来源。
所以，当一份草稿生成时，实际上是调用了我的声音和风格指南文件，然后根据这些来创作内容。
我给你们看看是什么样子的。这是我的风格指南，比如这是艾利克斯是谁，他在公司的角色，他想推广的自有资产，他的主要内容类型，他的关键整合，还有他关注的社交媒体账号。
你会看到克莱尔也在那里，那些给企业提供精确视角的人。这是第一部分，第二部分是声音指南。
基本上，当我启动内容机器的时候，它研究了所有我表现最好的X帖子和LinkedIn帖子，包括带声音和语气的执行摘要、钩子公式、内容结构、布局模式、话题分类。
这里有个排行榜，列出了我所有表现最好的十大X帖子、最好的LinkedIn帖子、我的核心DNA、我的第一规则，就是像给朋友发短信那样写作，还有我使用语言的例子。
自嘲式的自信。它真的深入研究了这些文件。这就是我完整的声音编码。然后，我们稍后会看到，这个过程中另一个非常重要的部分是，当内容机器为我起草了一份内容后，我会给它反馈，它会有从反馈中学习的强化循环。
还有另外一个在内容机器里的文件，是内容教训的markdown文件。
这些全都是我过去在起草内容时说过搞砸了的地方。它把这些都记成教训。所以，在语气方面，我说过语气不对的地方；在结构和流畅度方面，哪里不对它也会记下来。这样，它就会
在编辑内容时，总是检查内容教训的标记文件，确保它不会重蹈覆辙。
>> 那这些是通过编辑过程中的技能自动生成的吗？比如，如果你发现一些反馈，你是手动填写的吗？那是怎么创建出来的？
>> 内容机器的工作方式基本上是这样的：在内容起草完后，它会经过编辑过程，我一会儿给你看。然后我得到最终版的内容，接下来我会
对最终版内容给出反馈。等一切都完成了，我说'这个可以了，可以发布了'，基本上就会启动一个任务，作为这些串联技能的一部分，这就是"教训循环"。
这个教训循环就是：'让我看看提供给Alex的原始内容和新内容之间有什么差异。我们可以从中提炼出哪些可抽象的教训？'
然后我们会问Alex：'你希望把这些教训加到教训文件里吗？'如果他说是，我们就加进去。所以，就是这样运作的。然后为了带你走完整个流程，我还可以
实际操作给你看。这就是我的声音是如何被起草出来的。下一步就是，我已经分享了我选了一个点子，然后我像在接受这个访谈小组采访一样，把我的所有想法都唠叨了一遍。然后我选择，比如我想创建一个
LinkedIn帖子。它会用我的风格指南、我的声音标记文件以及我的内容教训标记文件，以我的声音起草出来。草稿完成后，它会经过"作家委员会"。就像我创建了六个访谈者角色一样，
我也创建了六个作家角色。比如David Perell、Sean Puri、Morgan Housel，还有那个"AI垃圾过敏者"。他们会阅读内容，然后打分，1到10分。如果总分低于
9分（满分10分），它就会进入修改循环，直到打到10分满分。然后就算完成了。内容完成后，我就可以进行再利用和分发，也就是说，有一个步骤我可以这么说：我想
把这个再利用一下。内容机器会问：你想把它改造成什么？我可以说，三条短推文，两条长LinkedIn帖子，然后它就会去查看我过去在这些不同帖子类型中的写作格式，
然后按照那种风格来写。
我觉得，这还是反映了几件事。第一，梳理你的工作流程。第二，有了AI，你就能引入一个专家委员会，而不用真的有一个专家委员会。所以，在理想世界里，我会被最顶尖的人采访。
但你知道吗？你可以在流程中接近这个效果。我觉得找到正确的反馈循环，在我构建这个流程的时候，怎么迭代地让它变得更好，
因为你能理解非结构化数据的输入和输出，这是以前做不到的，真的很有用。而且，AI是多模态的，我指的不只是图像到文本或者文本到
语音，或者语音到文本。我指的是文本到更短的文本，文本到更长的文本。所以，利用这些LLM的各个组成部分，我觉得这个用例就变得很好了。
本期节目由Customer.io赞助。你在这里，是因为你更想用AI而不是谈AI。用Customer.io，你描述你想构建的活动，AI代理就会为你创建受众、消息和
时机。你审查它，做任何修改，然后发布。不用花几个小时把工具和工作流拼凑在一起，你可以专注于真正驱动增长的工作。每个活动都和结果挂钩，所以你能看到什么是
有效的，接下来该做什么。超过9000个品牌用Customer.io把他们已有的数据变成客户记住的消息。访问customer.io/howiai试试吧。Customer.io，让每条消息更有影响力。我之前告诉过你，在开始之前，
我确实读你的文章，它们很好。所以，它们不像垃圾内容，但现场证明吧。现场做。我们怎么走这个流程？
让我打开我的Claude，给你看一个例子，看它已经运行过的，然后我们现场再做一次，如果搞砸了，我也乐意出丑。好，那我们看到的这就是
内容机器在运行，让你看看，这可能有用，内容机器作为插件存在于TenX的内部Claude里，基本上每个人都把它加到他们的机器上了。每当我推送更新
到Git上，人们就可以直接从这里自动更新。所以，我试着找一些东西，让公司里不懂技术的人也能轻松理解，因为我们推送更新，他们也能受益于这些
更新，我们待会儿可以聊聊，如何和公司里的每个人分享这个，让我们更接近我心目中的那个样子，我记得Sendbird的CEO和你聊过他们的内部quest。就像我们怎么
更接近那个目标。但先回到这个。基本上，它做的是先看我的来源，内部来源，它指出了好点子。比如这个就是关于单人还是多人的
AI框架，我们经常聊。我和一个银行的人聊过，他们和麦肯锡合作，麦肯锡给了他们一个想法，说这得花6个月来构建。他说他用Claude code一周就重建了。
我在销售电话上跟人说，我可能是世界上最差的销售员，这听起来挺有趣的。在一次电话里我提到，卖掉Morning Brew后，我很痛苦。那是个好的内容爆点。所以，
你看它真的抓住了具体的故事，然后从网络阅读器里，从我在个人资料文件里给的不同的来源提取。比如，一个是亚马逊投10亿美元在FDE上，Aaron Levie
对Ethan Mollick说，FDE是不是解决每个企业问题的办法，而另一边说，现在每个人都是构建者，交付才是难点。然后我就会选择一个我想要
真正展开的内容爆点。顺便说一下，内容机器里还有一件事，我要选一个想法来做成内容，但这里有几个想法我觉得都值得
展开。所以内容机器的一部分是，当公司里每个人都第一次设置它时，会创建一个vault，这个vault就是一个Notion数据库，Oracle生成的每个想法，即使你
不用，也会加到这个vault里。这样你以后可以进去提取想法。好，我选了第13个爆点。我觉得很有趣。Aaron Levie说FDE是上帝给地球最好的礼物，Mollick说
不，它不会解决所有问题。所以我选了这个，我想做更多研究，看看关于FDE都有哪些不同的论点，为什么Aaron和Ethan的观点不同。然后研究步骤
就启动了。你看，基本上就给我创建了一份研究简报，关于他们的观点、已经说了什么、我可以采取哪些反向或新颖的角度、我应该尝试回答哪些开放问题。
所以我事先读了。在采访过程中，如果我觉得有很好的引语，我也可以把它融入到我的回答中。然后我就进去，采访开始了。对了，我发现Larry King也
在这里。所以，Larry King就说，Levie说FDE赢是因为部署代理比人们想的更技术性。Mollick说它们会让人失望，因为真正的问题是组织结构和专业知识，不是代码。
他说：“你说他们俩都对，这里是他们遗漏的。”所以，用一两句话，他们遗漏了什么？我提供我的想法，比如FDE是不是解决一切的方案？我为什么同意或不同意Aaron和Ethan？
然后接下来的问题就是顺着我的回答继续问下去。所以，现在它会问：“面试小组真的训练有素，会尽可能从我这里挖掘具体细节和例子。”所以，蒂姆·费里斯会说：“给我举个例子，说明这种情况
真的令人头疼。你的团队在技术上做得不错。”所以，它让我讲一个客户故事。我就讲了。所以，我们就这样进行了五次问答。然后它说：“面试结束。”声音和教训都已锁定。所以，这就是
它查看我的内容教训和声音MD文件，然后创建LinkedIn草稿MD。这里，我关注的两个最聪明的人刚刚公开对AI领域最热门的工作提出了不同意见。他们俩都对，而这正是问题所在。顺便说一句，如果我要
对这条内容给反馈，我会说：“这感觉有点AI味儿，有点尴尬。他们俩都对，这种措辞，这种转折，就是最新的那种AI写法。”所以，我会给出这样的反馈，然后说把这条加进
我的内容教训里。这周，亚马逊承诺投入十亿美元用于部署工程，OpenAI和Anthropic也做了类似的事情。谷歌正在招聘数百人。所以，这基本上包含了我的所有
想法。比如，我的一个回答是：“公司需要做哪些准备才能在AI转型中取得成功？”然后它就直接用了我的原话，就像是说：“所以，如果你在为AI转型配备人员，你需要”
这些东西。它之所以很少写出垃圾内容，很大程度上是因为我基本训练它只使用我自己的话。所以我觉得这也是很重要的一点：这整个内容生产机制都建立在那个访谈的基础上，
那次和嘉宾的对话被转成了一大份Markdown格式的文字记录。而真正应该用到的词，除了标题和结尾可能例外，基本上就是这份记录里的内容。写作者的角色其实更像是在
像……像在塑造内容的泥坯，而不是凭空捏造新东西。所以在我看来，只有当内容机器真正产出垃圾时，那更多反映的是分享者没有在访谈环节提供足够好的
想法，而不是AI写得不好。
嗯，对。所以你的意思是，我们自己才是那堆垃圾。
我的看法就是这样：AI垃圾内容的搞笑之处，就在于大家其实是在指着自己的鼻子说：我脑子不够使。然后呢，它还带来另一个效果，我最近刚把它加进内容创作课程里，就是
我当时想：‘开始给我更多开头的例子吧，因为我想选择和比较。’所以，它会提供开头和结尾。那我接下来会这么做——哦，它连‘作者顾问团’都没运行。对，咱们这就运行它。
运行顾问团。现在它要做的是，它有了草稿，有了开头和结尾，它会运行编辑顾问团。如果评分在9分以上，它就会直接给我。如果不是，它就会进行一轮修改。然后我会在拿到之后，
像刚才给你的反馈那样，比如那条‘如果这样，那就那样’的句子有点俗，我会去确认它们被加到内容课程的markdown文件里，然后我
会再做最后一遍检查，然后发布。而且我的想法是——这也是我想加入内容机器的一个点——现在运行‘神谕’的时候，它没有拉取我之前应该考虑二次利用的内容。那应该成为我每天例行工作的一部分。
你看，它们现在都在评分，我已经能看出不会到9分，所以它们会运行完整的修改流程。
天哪，我喜欢这个。然后你会现场发布？
对，我们聊完这个，我马上就发布。
嗯，那接下来我想说的是，也许我们在这个流程结束后要讨论的是——你已经展示了从发现好点子到……
嗯。
我们怎么通过Yappers API，还是我们的朋友希拉里·格里德利，提取最好的想法。我们怎么用我们自己的语调塑造它，然后获得一些关键反馈并发布？但这不是100%靠AI。
你还有你的团队，你也在改变团队的行为，让所有人都接纳这种新的内容创作模式。那你能不能给我们讲讲你内容机器里非AI的部分，以及你们公司在尝试的一些新东西？
所以，这个东西其实……首先，我不想声称自己是员工倡导的发明者。这很久以前就有了，但我就是觉得，互联网和上面的平台已经让它变得可行了，但我觉得很多公司要么没跟上，要么太担心给每个员工一个扩音器的风险，结果就没做。我第一次尝试这个是在我的一家……
我的公司之一。
另外一家公司叫Storyarb，我们搞了个活动叫“占领互联网”，想法是搞个六到八周的活动。Storyarb的每个人都要在LinkedIn上发帖，也不是强制，但鼓励大家发，而且
有机会赢钱。我记得奖金好像是5000美元，赢家能拿到。唯一的规则是你创作的内容里，50%必须和Storyarb的业务相关。结果这个活动给公司带来了巨大的流量。
在我们搞“占领互联网”的那个季度，它带来了我们40%的潜在客户。还带来了大量招聘的顶级人才。所以我就知道，以后只要有这种机会，我一定会再干。
所以我们昨天刚启动了10X版本的类似活动。我来分享下具体细节。这个活动叫“10X创作者杯”，是一个为期一个月的挑战，目标是
让10X的每个人都发帖。参与方式就是你在LinkedIn或X上发帖，然后我们内部有个Slack频道叫“回复兄弟”，大家可以在那里看到每个人在创作者杯期间发的帖子。
规则是每发一次帖得10分。每回复公司里其他人的帖子得3分。每周我和联合创始人会选出一篇本周最佳帖子，
这样能加50分。还有每周的游戏，也有整个月的游戏。这里的关键是我们要鼓励大家发帖，而不是变成一场拼曝光量的竞赛，最后只有一个人
曝光量巨大。我们不想让人觉得没机会赢。而且我们希望让参与感很强，只要参与游戏就能得到点东西。所以，
举个例子，这周的游戏叫“满堂红”，如果公司里至少70%的人这周都发至少一次帖，那我们就解锁第一周的奖品，每个人能拿到一张
彩票，我们抽一个人，他这周能赢个几百美元。所以这周我们要发5000美元的奖品。但有趣的是，我们之前聊过这个。我跟他们说：“10X，咱们这是
在困难模式玩游戏。”你会说你们是在诚实模式吗？对，我觉得是这样，10X完全是白手起家，我觉得这逼着我们在某些事情上要有创意。其中一件事是
我们确实有世界上最好的工程师，我从来没跟这么优秀的人共事过。这有几个原因。但我们还没有像OpenAI或Anthropic那样的实验室光环。而且因为我们没有融到
大笔资金，我们也没有上过TechCrunch或者被顶级投资人提及的知名度。所以问题就来了，我们怎么在没有风投公司那些优势的情况下吸引顶尖人才？
我的看法是，你要让你的顶尖人才展示他们的优秀工作，而不是光说。所以对我来说，即使10X创作者杯没有给公司带来任何潜在客户，
如果它只是让更多的工程师知道10X，申请加入10X，理想情况下，如果整个活动能招到一名工程师，那这5000美元花得
太值了，因为你想想，要是找招聘机构挖一个工程师得花多少钱，这就完全值了。所以，我觉得我们应该利用白手起家这个特点，也就是要有
一种黑马心态，用游击营销，大家齐心协力，为10X营造这样一种氛围。
>> 我作为另一个白手起家的创始人，另一个把分发作为优势的白手起家创始人，我完全同意。我觉得另一件事是我们低估了告诉员工“我们鼓励你建立自己的平台”这个价值主张。
很多公司很短视，我确实听到CEO们说：“我可不想那个人到处炫耀自己多厉害，
不然有人会来挖他。”
>> 对。
>> 我就想，恰恰是这种不能谈论他们正在做的牛逼事情、不能建立个人品牌，才是他们离开公司的最主要原因。所以我觉得这
完全正确，而且我也很高兴看到另一个白手起家的创始人这么做。就像我说的，不是困难模式，也许确实是困难模式，但绝对是诚实模式。
>> 完全同意。而且我想到一件事，Anthropic在互联网上做得很好，他们基本上非常擅长员工影响，不管是有计划还是没计划。比如你想想
围绕Cloud Code和Co-work的那些人，不管是Tariq、Boris还是Felix，对吧？他们现在就是品牌的延伸，我更信任他们的产品，因为他们在谈论产品，而不是公司自己宣传。
完全同意，完全同意。亚历克斯，这次对话太棒了，给了我很多灵感。嗯，我也有一个类似的内容引擎，叫做Open Claw，他的名字是麦克斯，但你懂的，大同小异。那么，我希望能以几个快速问答来结束这次访谈。
一个是，你曾说你和世界上最优秀的工程师合作过，至少是你共事过的那些人。你觉得，现在什么样的工程师才算优秀？
我觉得，得是那种能非常深入地理解系统的人，就是那些让工程师一直很优秀的根本素质，但同时他们也要能灵活地完全拥抱让工作流程代理化。我觉得
现在有很多非常年轻的工程师，完全被AI洗脑了，但他们没有那种，你懂的，资深或高级工程师所具备的知识基础。然后，又有很多资深工程师，他们不够灵活，
无法改变自己的工作方式。我还想到一点，就是“前线部署工程师”这个概念比以往任何时候都重要，因为AI转型只能通过理解
企业的背景来实现。所以，是的，这是一方面。另一方面，我觉得世界上最优秀的工程师都想自己走得更远。我觉得他们想赌上自己的能力，这就是为什么我们付给工程师的薪酬像销售
人员一样，十倍。人们觉得我们疯了，但我的看法是，我想筛选出那些愿意赌上自己能力的人。
我同意。你知道我说了多少次让产品经理和工程师拿浮动薪酬吗？一直都是。一直都是。我觉得这是最好的。
这确实很棒，而且我们再次，嗯，有很多人对此议论纷纷，你看，确实有权衡，但我们已经考虑过所有方面，这让我们所有的人都紧跟前沿，因为他们获得杠杆的方式就是
了解技术的可能性。
好的，我也会为你的员工打call。我们播客里已经请过两位10倍人才了。嗯，两位都很棒，你应该去看看CJ和JJ的那两期。那么，你会雇佣那些名字只有两个字母的人吗？
我本来想说，我真的需要把名字改成AJ。我真的搞砸了10倍人才嘉宾的连贯性。
嗯，我娶了个EJ，所以如果你需要另一个J字辈的，我们可以算上。好，第二个问题，你展示了创作过程，我们看到了和JJ合作，也看到了和CJ一起写代码。那
我个人是怎么用的呢？就是你在个人生活中有没有觉得特别独特的AI使用场景？
我老婆有段时间在找工作。她在科技行业，找了阵子工作。我觉得我给她打造的一个挺有意思的工具，也是我没想到没人做过的，就是
招聘过程真的很难熬，找适合的工作也很难。但我觉得现在我们处于这个时代——就像我们在Morning Brew时说的，总会有人做出那种定制的
新闻简报，就像每个人都有自己的定制新闻。但基本上我做的是一个为她量身定制的招聘面板，每天她都会收到一封邮件，里面有10个根据她
之前的职位、她的领英资料和她的求职意向筛选出来的工作，还能打分。然后她可以直接从邮件里申请，系统会自动填好初始申请表格。所以这就是一个具体的例子。另外一个
我觉得这个挺经典的，就是定制儿童书。我们家里有个11个月大的宝宝，你知道，能让我们的宝贝布鲁克读到和她家人相关的故事，
对我来说也是个特别酷的应用。
我喜欢。你得加入我们的“我如何用AI”家长圆桌会议，因为我们有很多好点子。好了，最后一个问题，我问每个人：当你的AI神谕创作委员会给你一堆垃圾时，你的提示技巧是什么？你会
生气吗？还是贿赂它？
说实话，主要看我的沮丧程度和当时有多少时间。
我喜欢你慌慌张张的样子。你心里是不是在说，天哪，我该说实话吗？
不不不，要么我会直接说去他的，我就自己动手写。我觉得这通常是我的反应——算了，这玩意儿花的时间不值当，我自己写吧。
手工来做。或者我也会认真投入，花大量时间，觉得这不行。这些都是这些东西不行的地方。我敢肯定这些内容经验已经讲过了。为什么
这没被当成我已经教过的内容经验呢？所以我真的应该对它好一点，毕竟AI大佬总有一天会当我的老板，但说实话，我有时候对它挺凶的。
>> 所以经典的就是，不，你怎么能这样？
>> [笑声]
>> 我还没问过这个。
>> Alex，这真的很有帮助。我要偷走这些想法，这也是我搞这些采访的秘密原因。谢谢你分享给我们和我们的观众。我们在哪里能找到你，怎么联系你？
>> 我在X上是Business Barista，LinkedIn上是Alex Lieberman，我们公司叫10X。所以如果你是大公司需要AI转型帮助，就去10x.co找我们。
>> 如果你是优秀的工程师，Alex在招人。
>> 是的。
>> 全部。
>> 真的全部。
>> 据内容机器说，你在招所有人。
>> 没错。
>> 感谢来到How I AI。
>> 非常感谢。
>> 感谢观看。如果你喜欢这个节目，请在YouTube上点赞订阅，或者更好的是，留下评论告诉我们你的想法。你也可以在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你最喜欢的
播客应用上找到这个播客。请考虑给我们评分和评论，这能帮助其他人发现这个节目。你可以在howiaipod.com上看到我们所有的剧集并了解更多信息。下次见。